D-181 was used to being picked as a test subject
for the various dangerous and downright terrifying
experiments and lab work the SCP Foundation
had him perform at Secure Facility Site-32.
He’d been working for the organization for
nearly 5 years, and he considered every day
he was alive a blessing, and you would too
if you were a D-Class personnel.
While no one’s too sure on the exact methods
the SCP Foundation uses to recruit its D-Class
personnel, there are a few prevalent rumors,
most of which you’ve surely heard before.
Death row prisoners taken into custody by
the Foundation to be unwilling lab rats, ordinary
people that society wouldn’t miss that were
kidnapped off the streets, or sometimes just
volunteers, though we’re not sure who in
their right mind would willingly volunteer
for one of the most degrading, dangerous positions
in the entire Foundation.
The truth about D-Class is that every site
does it differently, and the Foundation is
well aware of the controversy among its personnel
that comes with recruiting and using D-Class
personnel.
Heck, some sites don’t even have D-Class,
citing their use as inhumane.
But at Site-32, things were ordinary, and
D-181 was one of the many D-Class personnel
drafted into the Foundation via the United
States prison system.
Day in and day out, D-181 would have to perform
tests and experiments, most of which he knew
next to nothing about.
Thankfully for him, D-181 had two benefits
that made his stay at Site-32 a little easier.
First, there was the fact that Site-32 was
a low-priority facility.
It was located far away from any major population
centers, and overall lacked the expensive
funding some of the larger sites had.
The anomalies contained there were still pretty
dangerous, but due to the lack of available
funding, most of what the Foundation was able
to afford at Site-32 was regulated to safe
and euclid-class objects.
Now, as we all know, object class has nothing
to do with danger levels, and instead is based
on the difficulty the Foundation has containing
a certain object more than anything else.
So, when a site, such as Site-32 is under-funded
due to being less of a priority to the larger
organization, they’re typically only going
to be containing the bare-minimum in terms
of expenses.
That means less expensive containment, and
less elaborate objects for D-181 to work with.
It wasn’t a guarantee of safety, as nothing
ever is in the SCP Foundation, but it was
at least beneficial to have an understanding
of what’s going on in the various experiments
D-181 had to perform throughout the day.
The second thing D-181 appreciated about Site-32
was a little less conventional.
The entire facility was staffed by women,
with the exception of male personnel being
used for testing purposes.
The reason for this is due to a very specific
detail about today’s anomaly, which we’ll
get back to, but it was something that D-181
never took for granted.
Of course, D-181 was an absolute buffoon when
it came to dating and relations between testing
subjects and researchers were discouraged
and in some cases forbidden.
However, he never gave up hope that he might
be able to now find a girlfriend while living
in a building that was less than 1 percent
male in population.
It's important that we state that D-181 was
always respectful to women and never stepped
out of line, which as far as D-Class go, makes
him top tier boyfriend material.
Maybe there’s hope for him some day, so
long as he survives the deadly, daily grind
of being on the lowest rung of the Foundation.
While those two things kept D-181 as happy
as someone could be while essentially being
enslaved to the Foundation, there was a lot
to be unhappy about in his position.
First, there was the general danger that came
with testing with anomalies every day, where
anything and everything could go wrong, and
your safety was never guaranteed.
Then, there were the dreams.
Most of the time, D-181’s waking state felt
like a dream, so that meant the images his
brain showed him at night were extra weird.
The horrors and oddities that D-181 witnessed
during the day always came back to haunt him
at night.
Whether it was a stack of talking bowling
balls attacking him in the grocery store,
or a tea cup that made his skin invert itself
every time he drank it, the SCP objects D-181
worked with always cropped up in his dreams
at night, and they always seemed to be worse.
D-181 asked the other D-Class personnel stationed
at the site if they had strange dreams too,
and most of them agreed that they experienced
them as well.
Apparently working for the Foundation fired
up the imagination in an extra special way
that seeped into the night time, when D-181
would ideally be receiving some well-deserved
sleep from the strangeness of the day.
But one dream was bothering D-181 significantly
more than usual.
It was a recurring one, happening again and
again every few nights.
The same series of events, playing out over
and over again.
The strangest part about it was that it didn’t
feel like a dream at all.
D-181 would be laying in his bunk inside Site-32’s
D-Class barracks, desperately trying to fall
asleep.
Eventually he would, but he wouldn’t realize
it.
D-181 would feel like he was asleep, but he
could still see the barracks around him, except
he couldn’t move at all.
D-181 was experiencing a form of sleep paralysis,
a phenomenon during falling asleep or waking
up, where a person is unable to move or speak.
Hallucinations during sleep paralysis are
common, but the whole experience typically
only lasts a few minutes.
For D-181, it lasted a lot longer, and he
was aware the entire time.
So, D-181 would be laying down in his bunk,
trying to fall asleep, when he would suddenly
become unable to move.
Then, from across the room, he’d see the
door to the barracks open up.
D-181 knew that the barracks were only accessible
to the upper-ranking personnel, and they never
came around.
First, D-181 saw a large cylinder move itself
slightly into the room.
Then the figure it was attached to waddled
its way through the door - a giant fabric
doll, so big that it could barely fit itself
into the door.
If D-181 could scream, he would.
He recognized the figure, an instance of SCP-2386,
one of the anomalies he was working on.
The doll walked slow and heavy, trying not
to collapse over its own weight.
It was made of pink fabric, with its face
stitched together with thread forming a sly
smile and two buttons for eyes.
It was terrifying What was even worse were
the two pairs of wings on the dolls back,
like the kinds you’d see on a butterfly
or a moth.
The brilliant patterns looked like they were
made of cloth, sewn to a pair of ordinary
insect wings and completing the doll’s patchwork
appearance.
The insect-doll combination stumbled towards
D-181, moving across the barracks slowly and
nearly falling over several times.
The creeping terror of the doll’s slow advance
only made D-181 try to move more, but he couldn’t.
He was completely paralyzed and subject to
whatever the doll was about to do to him.
Eventually, the doll made it close to D-181’s
bunk, standing over the bed and staring at
D-181 with its lifeless, button-eyed face.
It just stood there, staring.
D-181 was sweating, with tears in his eyes.
He tried to scream again, but nothing came
out.
And then, to make matters worse, the barracks
door opened again, and what made its way through
shook D-181 to his very core.
It was another doll, even bigger than the
other one, and behind it was another doll,
and then another.
Four dolls in total made their way into the
room and stumbled over to D-181’s bed.
They continued to stare, crowding around the
sleeping D-class like he was a television
set, and their favorite show was about to
begin.
Just when D-181 thought it couldn’t get
any worse, the dolls extended their stubby,
felted hands over his face, all four of them
moving in unison.
And then they stopped, and D-181 heard their
voices.
Well, not their voices exactly, but voices
nonetheless.
High-pitched, barely-human, childish voices
started whispering to him.
They weren’t coming from the dolls, but
they could talk, D-181 was positive this is
what they’d sound like.
“You’re doing such a great job.”
One said.
“You’re the Foundation’s greatest asset.”
“We love you, D-181, we love you.”
All of these seemingly innocuous phrases were
things said to D-181 while he was surrounded
by the giant dolls.
On paper, they sound encouraging, but the
context of the situation and the way they
were said made them anything but.
And this would continue for what seemed like
hours, with the dolls crowding D-181 and speaking
to him in his paralyzed state, shouting the
most deceptively kind things possible over
and over again, all while D-181 was aware
the entire time.
But before he would wake from this awful dream,
one of the instances would lift their stubby
hand forward, directly hovering over D-181’s
arm and the doll’s appendage would caress
him, squeezing and playing with his arm like
it were a toy.
By morning, when D-181 awoke from his dream,
he felt like he was never asleep in the first
place, and that he could remember every agonizing
second of the past night’s experience.
This would continue almost every other night.
As soon as D-181 would fall asleep, the doll
dream would occur again.
As soon as he woke up, he’d feel like he
got next to no sleep the night before.
It was draining him, and inhibiting D-181
from performing his duties accordingly.
One day during testing, D-181 fell asleep
in the middle of an experiment, and dropped
an important component to the object he was
working with, which nearly set the entire
facility on fire.
After that, D-181 knew that something had
to change.
D-181 recognized the dolls.
They were instances of SCP-2386, which he
had worked with previously.
In fact, it was the experiments with SCP-2386
that injured D-181 on his right arm, causing
an infectious spot to crop up.
What caused this, and what exactly is SCP-2386?
We’ll get to all of that soon enough, but
we need to focus on the dreams.
It was three weeks into the dreams, three
weeks since D-181 was injured during testing,
and three weeks since D-181 had a good night’s
sleep.
He met with Dr. Shaw, the head researcher
in charge of SCP-2386 experimentation, and
someone who worked with D-181 many times.
Dr. Shaw and D-181 sat down, and prepared
an interview.
She began:
“Good Morning, D-181.
You say you've been having recurring dreams?”
D-181 shuffled in his seat a bit.
“Yeah, hi, doc…
Ever since I got this thing!
It wasn’t that bad at first.”
D-181, of course, was talking about the red
spot on his arm.
Shaw asked him to explain the dreams, and
D-181 did.
He explained how he would be in his bunk,
feeling almost awake but not quite, when giant
versions of SCP-2386 would make their way
into the room.
They’d gather around his bed and stare at
him, shouting things, and caressing his infected
spot.
Dr. Shaw listened intently.
D-181 was clearly shaken up from relaying
the experience to another person.
He continued, barely able to hold himself
together.
You see, something had changed the night before
D-181 spoke to Dr. Shaw.
For the first time, the dream was altered.
“Actually, last night, they did something
different.
Another one came in.
It had something with it.
It looked like a baby one!
It was all wrapped up in this white cloth.
They said something about wanting to show
me what I was working towards…
They pulled back the cloth over its head and
it was a bug's head!
Woke me right the heck up.”
A baby with a bug’s head was definitely
strange imagery, but Dr. Shaw was unsure what
it all could mean.
She knew SCP-2386 were insect-like, and with
the way D-181’s infection was looking, her
brain began concocting a strange, but potentially
true theory.
One that wasn’t looking good for D-181.
But before we get into that, let’s talk
about what SCP-2386 really is.
They’re known among Foundation personnel
at Site-32 as “Pink Ladies”, and they’re
a diminutive species that outwardly resemble
patchwork dolls made of traditional fabric.
Think that creepy Raggedy Ann doll your grandmother
has, but ten times more degraded, a whole
lot more pink, and straight up insectoid in
nature.
They’re not as big as the ones in D-181’s
dream, but they’re definitely as scary,
with stitched-on faces and a pair of moth
wings on their backs.
In fact, the actual SCP-2386 instances range
from only 7 to 9 centimeters tall.
Autopsies on dead instances of SCP-2386 showed
resemblances to human botflies and silkworms,
two species of insects that are absolutely
nasty.
It's terrifying to imagine something so outwardly
cuddly could look so downright ugly on the
inside, but that’s what SCP-2386 are.
But don’t try hugging them either.
Their cotton fiber exoskeleton is as durable
as it is gross, and they’re not the kind
of cuddly doll you’d want to take to bed
at night.
In the wild, SCP-2386 are found in hives resembling
similarly patterned seat cushions.
Big mounds of cloth host to tons of these
tiny terrors, with the biggest hive the Foundation
ever came across being the size of a large
sofa.
These hives are commonly found near suburban
environments, and sometimes even inside occupied
housing.
Imagine coming home to find a brand new sofa
inside your house, and then realizing that
it's actually home to thousands of SCP-2386
instances.
When SCP-2386 leave their colonies, it is
primarily to feed on smaller insects, and
seek out hosts for reproductive purposes.
Despite their cute but gross appearances,
SCP-2386 become hostile if approached by males
of any species, and will target them accordingly.
That’s why Site-32 only employs male personnel
for testing purposes.
As soon as they’re within range of a male
subject, SCP-2386 will outstretch one of its
appendages and extend a pair of scissor-like
claws from it, before swarming the male.
This is what happened to D-181, which resulted
in the red, infected spot on his arm.
Conversely, female subjects in the presence
of SCP-2386 are treated entirely differently,
with the instances caring for them, presenting
them with small gifts, and attempting to play
with them.
During the spring and summer seasons, SCP-2386
will enter their mating season and cease their
hostilities towards males.
Instead, they’ll treat them with the same
level of kindness they do with females.
But this kindness is just a front.
When given the opportunity, SCP-2386 will
slice a small incision into the male subject,
and pump them full of about 30 to 65 eggs
underneath their skin.
Within 24 hours, the incised area will resemble
patterned cloth, and genetic tests reveal
it to be composed of the same material as
SCP-2386’s hives.
In the weeks that follow, this area will spread
across the subject’s body, and eventually,
it will open to reveal fully grown, adult
instances of SCP-2386, who burst from the
patchwork skin.
Dr. Shaw recognized that this is what was
happening to D-181, and immediately got him
to Site-32’s medical ward.
D-181 was strapped down to the table, and
tried not to freak out over what he knew was
about to happen.
The dreams were acting as a warning, and SCP-2386
was clearly looking forward to having D-181
bear the next generation of insect-dolls.
Thankfully, Dr. Shaw caught the infection
before the patchwork skin was able to fully
take root, meaning that the eggs underneath
D-181’s skin were premature.
Thankfully, there was still time.
Surgery was carried out immediately, and the
doctors weren’t surprised to discover a
colony of premature SCP-2386 eggs underneath
D-181’s arm.
They were removed from the body and thrown
into storage for further research purposes.
D-181, after waking up from the surgery, thanked
Dr. Shaw.
At least now he wouldn’t have to deal with
those horrible dreams, and the stinging, swollen
sensation underneath his arm.
Unfortunately, he was still a D-Class personnel
working for the Foundation, and would have
many more intense experiences after this one.
But D-181’s gratefulness would soon subside.
Within a few hours, D-181 began to ask Dr.
Shaw if he could see SCP-2386’s enclosure.
He spent the past few weeks absolutely terrified
of the species, but for whatever reason, he
felt like he had unfinished business with
the anomalies.
He wanted to see them again.
Dr. Shaw became suspicious, and understandably
denied D-181 entrance from the enclosure.
But this wasn’t enough.
D-181 became violent, and tried to force himself
into the containment chamber.
He needed to see them!
He couldn’t explain why, but he felt incomplete.
Eventually, D-181 was subdued and returned
to his quarters, but his symptoms continued
throughout the weeks.
He was depressed, and frequently made reference
to SCP-2386 as being lost, or unrightfully
taken away from him.
To Dr. Shaw, what happened was clear.
D-181 had been affected mentally upon receiving
the SCP-2386 eggs.
This was a safety mechanism induced by the
anomaly in the case of birthing complications,
so D-181 would feel compelled to receive another
batch of eggs into his body if the first batch
was lost or damaged.
It was disgusting, and Shaw was positive it
would subside after a few more weeks, but
what kept her up at night wasn’t the same
dreams D-181 had, or the terror of SCP-2386.
It was the image of D-181, scared and out
of his mind, clawing that containment chamber
door, begging to be used as a host for SCP-2386’s
next batch of eggs.
Now go check out “SCP-3004 - Insect God
- Imago” and “SCP-439 - Bone Hive” for
more anomalous SCP Explained videos that will
bug you out!